hey 42 here how many friends do you have
how many friends would you like to have
actually a better question would be how
many friends can you have in the 90s
British anthropologist Robin Dunbar
looked at the correlation between the
brain size of different primates and the
size of their social groups by
extrapolating these numbers to the human
brain size Dunbar postulated that the
maximum social relationships any one
human can maintain is around 150
specifically Dunbar found that a larger
species neocortex the top part of the
brain the largest social groups that
species come maintain this is because
each human friendship requires the
dedication of a portion of one's
resources the resource of time required
to meet of them occasionally so they
don't forget to you exist or vice versa
the resource of memory you have to
remember a huge amount of details about
each one of your friends foods they do
and don't eat what type of films are
music they like what angers them what
makes them laugh and cry what they do
for a living through their partner or
spouses and who their friends are and
then there's the resource of emotional
support at some point all friends will
call upon you for your emotional support
in times of need we all have a limited
amount of support and friendly advice to
go around expend too much of it and
you'll start to feel more like a shrink
than a friend put all these factors
together and you start to see how
maintaining more than 150 relationships
isn't possible for any human some people
can have a few more or somewhat fewer
but 150 is the general limit imposed by
our brains our biology look at the world
around you and you will start to notice
Dunbar's number everywhere unapologetic
tribal groups in our hunter-gatherer
days were 150 and it still held true
thousands of years later the Domesday
book showed that
the average village size in England was
150 the average number of wedding guests
is 141 150 maybe how many relationships
one can have but in reality there is a
much much smaller limit on how many
close friends you can have which may be
a cause of some relief if you're sat
there thinking wait I'm supposed to have
150 friends I have like two well come
down to is absolutely plenty because the
truth is the limit is around about 5 in
2007 Robin Dunbar was back at us again
proving were all terrible at knowing
lots of people by examining the call
logs from the phones of 27,000 Europeans
he deducted that people are
realistically capable of having 5 close
friendships including intimate relations
in fact for the average Joe 80% of all
their calls are made to the same 4
people but 42 I have 325 friends on
Facebook and my mate Dave he's got over
700 but I secretly think he's a prick
well you've just nicely Illustrated my
next point no you don't because they're
not your friends Facebook friends are no
more than numbers on a server go through
your friends list and you'll notice that
most of them are people you've only met
once and will probably never see again
simply friends of someone you want
worked with almost likely people you are
supposed to be friends with but you
secretly hate their guts none of these
people counts as friends I wish I was
sorry to disappoint you but I'm not
because if you genuinely think that
these are all close friends and not just
casual acquaintances then you have truly
undervalued the close bond of a genuine
friendship you cannot truly consider
someone a friend unless you converse
with them face-to-face on a regular
basis and you can rely on them to help
you out in times of need and vice versa
now if anything I've said has made you
doubt your relationships
anybody straps yourself insani because
unfortunately I've
some more bad news for you you see it
statistically likely that half of your
friends don't even like you a study at
MIT analyzed the relationships between
eighty-four so-called friends aged
between 23 to 30 eight everyone was
asked to rank everybody else in the
study between zero and five zero meaning
I don't know that person and five meant
they're one of my best friends 94% of
people expected their friendships to be
reciprocated but astonishingly only 53%
of them actually were that means that
half of the people who were supposed to
be a participant's friend said they
didn't actually consider that
participant to be their friend the
sample size using this study was very
small but other data sources containing
ninety two thousand individuals say that
reciprocity rates of friendships is
actually between 34 to 53 percent this
is rather sad and gives one cause for
concern especially when a study from
Harvard University found that having no
friends can be just as damaging to your
health as smoking but there is a
positive you can take away here you
could call half of your friends from
your life and probably be happier this
of course means that you have to first
know who the false friends are which is
easier said than done
so before you rock up to work tomorrow
and tell everyone in HR to f off which
you should totally do by the way it's
incredibly cathartic you should probably
think it over so how do you know who is
only pretending to be your friend well
there's no secret technique here but one
of the most obvious ways is to think
where for that person has ever shared a
secret with you
sharing a secret with another requires a
huge amount of trust which one would
only do with someone they admire and
truly respect as a friend also when you
are with your group of friends are you
always the one they asked to take the
pick
if so then sorry palates probably you
however it's likely that things haven't
always been this way and that
reciprocity levels amongst friendship
groups have dropped significantly in
recent decades this is because the
perceived value of her friendship has
dropped with the advent of social media
today a new friendship can be created
with a tap or a swipe and just as easily
removed from our lives in an online
world driven by a vicious cycle of
instant gratification and gamification
friends are seen as less or more than
points to collect in the game of life
when some people choose to accept a
friend request the fort usually passes
through their mind of how will this make
me look better the problem is that this
is enough Emma - why Homo sapiens
evolved to form friendships in the first
place why do you think our species out
if all the hominids came to dominate all
of us why not chimpanzees though are
once rivals Neanderthals after all they
had larger craniums than sapiens well it
certainly wasn't because of our strength
or of a species there were many species
bears lions chimpanzees and indeed
Neanderthals that could tear our limbs
off like pretty little chicken wings and
contrary to what you may think it wasn't
because of our large brains
if so elephants would be CEOs and
politicians no even though that is a
rather nice image okay it was because of
our superior intelligence but it was
something far more specific about our
intelligence in particular after all of
a species were and still are
extraordinarily intelligent but humans
dominated the playing field because of
the unique way that Homo sapiens brains
evolved to be able to form complex
social bonds over animals bees
chimpanzees formed social groups but
none had the inherit ability to do so
quite like Homo say
Homo sapiens can and as far as we know
this is unique in the animal kingdom
gossip about others behind their back so
that tribesman knew who to avoid in
their tribe and in other tribes and also
Homo sapiens have the ability to imagine
things that we have never seen before
like when a fellow tribesman were to
describe a beautiful waterfall over near
that big pointy Rock over there our
ability to form these super complex
social groups and maintain knowledge on
who doesn't like whom who was willing to
protect us when hunting and most
importantly who stole jon's Rock are the
very reasons why Homo sapiens were able
to work together to form groups that
collectively were greater and many times
more formidable than their some parts
friendships allowed us to hunting groups
protect each other and look after our
sick so ask yourself when you and your
best friends are together are you
greater than your some parts can you do
amazing things together and forge great
memories could you rely on them in times
of need if not it's possible they could
be on the negative side of your 50% I've
just launched my first book which I'm
crowdfunding sticker flakiness a
thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and beyond if you'd like to get
your hands on a first edition signed
copy then head on over to unbound the
links in the description watch the
launch video if you haven't already and
pledge today thank you